First, there was the planet.
And then came people.
And for thousands and thousands of years, they coexisted happily.
The planet and everything in it worked together,...
...which was good.
But it wasn't quite good enough...
...because these machines used fossil fuels like coal and oil.
And fossil fuels release lots of carbon into the atmosphere.
And lots of carbon in the atmosphere...
...is the main cause of climate change.
So, people looked for a different kind of energy,...
...inventing smart new ways to move, store and generate carbon-free energy.
The kind of inventing that gets people at Google very excited.
So, that's our plan: to be the first major company in the world...
...to run on carbon-free energy by 2030, which is good.
But it isn't quite good enough, because it takes much more than just one company...
...to create a carbon-free future.
That's why we're using our technology to help other companies....
...and governments and institutions everywhere become carbon-free.
And we're giving billions of people access to tools and information...
...to lead a more carbon-free life.
So that for thousands of years to come, people and planet...
...can coexist happily.
The planet and everything in it working together again.